Whenever we do recognition machine
learning, what's going to help me?
It's the data.
The data are the first thing
that's going to help me.
There's somebody else
I'm going to bring
them along in a minute.
So here we have some images of pictures,
and as you can see in the red circles,
there are some pixels that are from,
say, skin.
And there are pixels
that are not from skin.
And let's suppose I just want to
label a pixel or little patches.
Is that skin, or is there not skin?
By the way, this is a cute,
little thing for those of you out there.
We did a bunch of skin
detection et cetera.
And in Sandy Pentland's lab, and
I think Thad Starner was involved back
when he was a student, it turns out
the color of skin is pretty constant.
The luminance changes, right?
So some people, you may have noticed
are darker than other people.
But they're darker,
they just have more of the same pignent,
pigment, right, the melanin pigment.
So when you look at skin in a color
space, if you remove the illuminant,
it's actually possible to detect
skin for a very wide range
of how dark the skin is, using the same
color removing the illuminant.
Now you have to worry about lighting and
a bunch of other things.
But it makes sense, right,
because there's only one pigment.
Anyway, we're going back,
we're looking at skin color.
There's a bunch of pixels that are skin
color and a bunch of pixels are not.
So, what am I going to do?
Well, what I do is,
I'm going to take the skin pixels, all
the pixels that I, somebody supervised,
remember supervised learning,
have classified as being skin pixels.
And I"m going to build a little
histogram of their feature.
Now, the feature that
we're using here is hue.
Hue is the, essentially the color
with the amount of brightness and
saturation removed.
It's, you know, how red, greenish,
bluish, yellowish is, is the color.
And what this is, is this is a little
box that's essentially the percentage.
It's a histogram that's
the percentage of pixels,
of the skin pixels, that have this hue.
And a histogram is an approximation
to the probability distribution.
But notice that it's
the probability of getting
that particular hue
given that it's skin.
It is not the probability that
it's skin given these hues, okay?
This is the,
remember the likelihood, all right?
Well what do I do after
I've done the skin pixels,
well I do the not skin pixels,
I build another graph, right?
And in fact what's interesting
is you'll notice there's
a little bit of overlap here, right?
That's not too surprising.
There are some, in fact in real life
there actually would have been some down
here too, et cetera, whatever.
Because, you know,
there are skin colored pixels
in the non skin world, okay?
And there are some skin that, you know,
people go and get tattooed or something.
I dont know, whatever.
You know, but in general I'm not
going to have a clean separation, but
I'm going to have a distribution
that hopefully has some
differences between them.
And again,
this is the probability of getting
that hue given that it's not skin.
And it's not the probability
of the other way around.
So all we have at the moment
is the probability of getting
a hue given that it's skin, probability
of giving a hue given it's not skin.
But what, what do we really want to do?
Well, somebody gives us a picture.
This is a stunning picture
of the Beatles, actually.
I've never seen this picture before.
Well, that's not totally true.
I saw it the last time I gave this
lecture, but you know what I mean.
Anyway, we get in a new picture, and
what we want to do is we want to label
each pixel as being skin or not skin.
Or more precisely, we want to know the
probability that it's skin or not skin,
given say, some of the color.
So, do I have the probability
that something's skin,
given its hue on this slide?
Megan, do I have it?
Yes.
>> Yes.
>> Wrong.
No, I have the probability of
a hue given that it's skin, right?
What do we have to do?
Well you've all seen this company wor,
coming.
Where else do I get help from,
besides the data?
I get a help from Dr.
Thomas Bayes, okay?
Bayes rule, remember Bayes rule?
We did Bayes rule now a couple of times?
Bayes rule says that the probability
that it's skin, given x and
that's referred to as the posterior.
It can be written as a prior.
If I pull out some pixel and
I don't tell you anything about it,
what's the probability it's skin?
That's the prior.
And I multiply that by the likelihood,
P of x given that it is skin.
Now that we do have that.
Remember those histograms?
That's the probability of getting
a hue given that it's skin.
So that we have from the data,
all right?
But the prior is added in here.
And in fact, if we remove,
since we've got our measurement,
we can sort of pull that out.
We did that last time for
our particle filtering, actually.
We can say that the probability that
something is skin, given a measurement,
is the likelihood, or is proportional
to the likelihood times the prior.
Which all brings us to the question
of where do you get your prior from?
Okay, we've run into this problem before
when we told you to go to get in your
car, drive to Greece,
go to the oracle, get a prior.
Well that's one thing you could do,
but airfare to Greece is expensive.
So we have to do something else and
Steve sites,
wrote this Bayes rule in use/abuse.
It was kind of cute, I kept the joke.
Thanks Steve.